so in the last video I described how to
interpret three-dimensional graphs and I
have another three-dimensional graph
here it's a very bumpy guy and this
happens to be the graph of the function
f of X Y is equal to cosine of X
multiplied by the sine of Y and you know
I could also say like that this graph
represents some I could also say that
this graph represents Z is equal to that
whole value because we think about the
output of the function as the Z
coordinate of each point and what I want
to do here is describe how you can
interpret the relationship between this
graph and these these functions that you
know by taking slices of it so for
example let's say that we took a slice
with this plane here and what this plane
here is is it represents the value x
equals 0 and you can kind of see that
because this is the x axis so when
you're at 0 on the x axis you know you
pass through the origin and then the
values of y and z can go freely so you
end up with this this plane and let's
say you want to just consider where this
cuts through the graph okay so we'll
limit our graph just down to the point
where it cuts it and I'm going to draw a
little red line over that spot now what
you might notice here that red line
looks like a sinusoidal wave in fact it
looks exactly like the sine function
itself you know it passes through the
origin it starts by going up and this
this makes sense if we start to plug
things into the original form here
because if you take and if you take F
and you plug in x equals 0 but then we
still let Y range freely what it means
is you're looking at cosine of 0 x sine
of Y sine of Y and what is cosine of 0
cosine of 0 evaluates to 1
so this whole function should look just
like sine of Y
and that when we let sign when we let y
run freely on the output which is still
represented by the Z coordinate will
give us this graph it's just a normal
two-dimensional graph that we're
probably familiar with and let's try
this at a different point let's see what
would happen if instead of plugging in x
equals 0 let's imagine that we plugged
in y equals 0 and this time before I
graph it and before I show everything
that goes on let's just try to figure
out purely from the formula here what
it's going to look like when we plug in
y equals 0 so now I'm going to write
over on the other side we have I have X
will still run freely Y is going to be
fixed at 0 and what this means is we
have cosine of X so maybe you expect to
see something that looks kind of like a
cosine graph and then sine of 0 except
what is sine of 0 sine of 0 cancels out
and just becomes 0 which multiplied by
cosine of X means everything cancels out
and becomes 0 so what you would expect
is that this is going to look like a
constant function that's constantly
equal to 0 and let's see if that's what
we get so I'm going to slice it with y
equals 0 here and you know this is we
look at the y axis we see when it's 0
and X and Z both run freely I'm going to
chop off my graph at that point and
indeed it chops it just at this straight
line the straight line that goes right
along the right along the x axis but
let's say that we did a different
constant value of Y rather than Y equals
0
so rather than y equals 0 and we'll
erase all of this let's say that I cut
things at some other value so in this
case what I've chosen is y is equal to
PI halves and it looks it looks kind of
like we've got a wavy here and it looks
like a cosine wave and you can probably
see where this is going you know this is
when X is running freely and if we
we start to imagine plugging this in
I'll just actually write it out
we've got cosine of X and then Y is held
at a constant sine of PI halves sine of
PI halves is just this just always
equals one so we could replace this with
one which means the function as a whole
should look like cosine X so again the
multivariable function with frozen Y and
we're letting X range freely and it ends
up looking like a cosine function and I
think a really good way to understand a
given three-dimensional graph when you
see it so let's say you look back at the
original graph and we don't have
anything going on and get rid of that
little line so you've got this graph and
it looks wavy and bumpy and a little bit
hard to understand at first but if you
just think in terms of holding one
variable constant it boils down always
into a normal two-dimensional graph and
you can even think about as you're
letting planes kind of slide back and
forth what that means for the the
amplitude of the wave that you see and
things like that this becomes especially
important by the way when we introduce a
notion of partial derivatives